separately chris beyond the guys opting
out there is
a list of guys who are coveted 19
positive who cannot join their teammates
until they have three negative tests
and some of the names on that lane
johnson the eagles right tackle who
held an ol mastermind summit in dallas a
few weeks ago where there was not much
evidence of social distancing or mask
wearing
kenny galladay and tj hawkinson of the
lions both on
the covet 19 positive list along with
vikings receiver and first round pick
justin jefferson
and look here's the thing and anytime we
talk about guys testing positive there
will be that
segment chris of the media and of the
population
that says these guys are all fine
they're gonna be healthy they're
asymptomatic it's no big deal why are we
worried about it well
okay fine you're right apart from the
fact that they may spread it
but here's the reality it doesn't matter
if they're symptomatic or not
they're not allowed to play until
they're negative yeah they're not
allowed to play or practice until they
can pass the test multiple times
so whether or not they have a fever
whether or not they have any
breathing problems whether or not they
have any of the symptoms that have
caused many people illnesses
it doesn't matter if you're positive
you're not playing
that's the thing that potentially is
going to bring down the nfl this year if
so many guys are positive at one given
time
even if they're asymptomatic there
aren't enough guys to play
that and that so so basically the
arguments that people want to throw out
they're like oh they're fine they're
fine
it doesn't that doesn't matter for this
context what matters in this context is
if you're positive
you ain't getting on the field yeah so
that's where the concern comes from not
from whether or not guys are sick
whether or not guys are allowed to play
and they're not allowed to play if
they're testing well
yeah well yes so those are the rules and
you know the people that are saying oh
these guys are fine yeah okay great we
know that
yeah most of them will be fine but i
mean what's it gonna take to change
public
opinion you know one two guys dying you
know or
a superstar on ventilators and then
people are gonna like oh oh god this
thing is serious whoa you know so that's
just a stupid thought i don't know what
else to say about that
you know it's wrong we know it's
dangerous yes do we know it's just like
if you get it
you're just gonna like die on the spot
no we understand there's a lot of people
that have had very
to little no reaction of coba 19
but we know there's some other people
and and some people we'd classify as you
know
adonises and whoa i can't believe that
guy got sick or do that who have gotten
sick and really had a struggle with it
an issue
so you know it's not foolproof that way
and you know do you want to be the guy
that's responsible for
for doing that and giving it to your
locker room or whatever it may be but
um you know lane johnson what do you
think there
i mean he was very much in his statement
going to make sure that he he
addressed the o-line summit because i
know that you made a point of it on pft
and you should have that's right it was
ridiculous yes
all these guys crammed together in a
room at a hotel with a hot wing eating
contest
breathing all over each other no masks
no social distancing
he pointed out he was negative before
and negative after well just because
you're negative right after doesn't mean
that you don't already have it in you it
takes a few days for it to manifest
itself
so that's not disposit the bottom line
is however he got it wherever he got it
he was engaging
in unsafe behaviors that create
a higher chance of getting it even if he
got it somewhere else
he was doing something he shouldn't have
done and uh look we hope he's fine
along with all of the other players who
test positive along with anyone else who
tests positive
but we know what's going on here that's
what contributes to this twilight zone
dynamic
of the entire pandemic chris the fact
that so many people are fine and they're
walking around giving it to others
oblivious to the fact that they even
have it uh and then some of the others
end up
dying that it's that's what makes it so
hard to really get our arms around it
and understand what we're dealing with
and get people to take it
seriously one quick point before we go
sean payton acknowledged yesterday and
sean payton the saints coach also a
member of the competition committee
he thinks there will be suspended games
this year or at least there possibly
will be suspended games
driven by teams wiped out at a specific
position group yeah that's the key right
and and and that's something peter king
hinted at earlier in the week on
football morning in america
if you get your offensive line room
wiped out the commission ray exercise
discretion
just postpone the game or cancel the
game now peyton used the word suspended
i don't know if that means the game gets
made up but
i we have to prepare for the possibility
that 32 teams are not going to play 16
games
it's going to change the landscape of
the year i mean think about this think
about we get to week five
and there's one team that's played four
games in a row right and nothing's
happened they've been lucky to dodge all
bullets
think about the team maybe think about
the team they're playing
now they haven't played football in two
weeks because they've been ravaged by
the so now they've only played two games
you know that team that's played four is
gonna have a great advantage you know at
some point hey rest is good but then at
one point
rest becomes oh crap we're not getting
enough experience getting to play
getting to
investigate and see the issues of our
team and continue to build and formulate
to go forward in a positive manner it's
going to be a great competitive
advantage
again for those teams who can stay clean
and continue to play
and stay you know on the move and
continuing to improve their craft and
other teams might be play a week off a
week play
two weeks off a week and that could
throw you off rhythm for the season and
be a great you know equal
uh or you know competitive equal
whatever the hell i'm trying to say
there you know what i'm saying
equalizer equalizer embolizer echelons
i'm just throwing out words from
synthesis all right one guy didn't play
in 14 weeks last year actually 15
altogether he's trying to get back into
the nfl and a big time quarterback wants
him
on his team the latest with antonio
brown when pft live continues right
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports